Um, Nicholas Diorio, aka Epic Review. What's his What's the name
of his
>> Can I say something to you, Nick? I really like you.
>> Hope you enjoy me giving Nick Oreo money rather than
funding your sad cold life. Hope your EGGS DWINDLE FASTER.
WHAT DO WE SAY? [music]
Yeah, yeah, yeah. TFFWD. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think so. I might
have to go through some of this stuff in the background a little
bit. Hold on. Let's see if we >> I'm a big fan of Nicholas
Diorio. What can I say? You do your research.
>> I don't know. >> I know. >> Not only is
that offensive, it's also bad. Like it's a bad impression.
>> It's a great impression. But what actually happens here
is he's just going to agree with his r- wine mom audience and
say it's offensive without thinking about it. He was not thinking
about hypocrisy. He was just saying, "Yeah, it's offensive."
And again, I do think it's incumbent on you to say why it's offensive
cuz there's no part of that accent that sounds Israeli, okay?
It's offensive because Ela Klein is cognitively impaired. That's
why it's offensive. You are mocking a r-
That's why it's offensive, okay? >> fan of Nicholas Diorio.
What can I say? You do your research.
>> I don't know. >> I know. >> Not only is
that offensive, it's also bad. Like it's a bad impression. >> I'm
a big fan of Nicholas >> We go back. We got to read this
Reddit post, okay? So, after after that clip where Nicholas calls
it offensive, there's a Reddit post on Clip Live where he says
this, right? This is on the Clip Live subreddit. Mocking someone's
accent  second language speaking is offensive to most
communities partaking in it in targeting Ela this way.
They're not mocking her accent. They're not mocking her like
ESL-ness.
She shouldn't be ESL. She's been living in America for a long
time.
It dude, you're barely ESL if you live in Israel.
They speak English in Israel all the time. If you're in any secular
part of Israel, you know how to speak English.
It's not that she's ESL at all. What are we talking about here?
That's not really an opinion either. There is a huge double standard
in in what people are allowed to ethically
I mean probably that they don't like them, but this isn't in
his criticism at all, right?
>> so bad. Like it's a >> In the in the criticism
of it being an offensive and bad accent, that's not
Any of this stuff. This is all stuff you say after the fact,
okay? There was another comment there for sure that he thrown
down. Someone says, "Less grifting, more just beating a dead
horse because it's super easy and very profitable. Also, part
of it is likely just audience capture. A lot of his current fans
are H3 fans, so he's probably more inclined to pull his punches
a bit more often even when he's criticizing them." And Nick responds,
"None of my punches are pulled. The opinions stated are mine."
That's the funny thing is cuz I do think what's happening here
is he's just going along with the audience. He's just reaffirming
the audience cuz he's not really he's just on autopilot, right?
He's not really thinking about stuff. And then he says, "Well,
no, I none of the punches are pulled. All the opinions stated
are mine." Well, you said it was offensive.
And you come up with some cope after the
None of that makes it offensive, by the way, right?
When you say that's offensive, you're saying that's offensive
to me, not that's offensive in other crowds that that person
rolls in. The idea that something's also augie little here in
my
Objectively it is as in offensive.
There is nothing that is objectively offensive. It's based on
your
Objectively offensive doesn't exist. It is a subjective
like evaluation.
What are we talking about?
I don't know. I
Why you got to sweep this random comment? Why you got to sweep
here, Augie? Pull the broom out for something tangible, something
that matters. So [__] up. It's actually [__]
up. Apparently, Chille Willy just put out a new video on this.
Okay, we're going to watch that real quick.
Nicholas DeOrio is a >> Something's been bothering me lately,
>> Nicholas DeOrio is a total
loser. >> And I just can't shake it. Last week we talked
about H3H3 and them taking offense to Anisa's impression of Ela
Klein. And while they were offended, somebody else decided to
be offended on their behalf. >> I'm a big [snorts] fan
of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I say? You do your >> research.
[laughter] >> I don't know. >> Not only is that offensive,
it's also bad. Like, it's a bad impression. >> The Ultimate
Review Guy thought that impersonating Ela Klein was a bridge
too far. That's a little offensive. By the way, the wiggler that
he uses as his little persona, because God forbid he shows his
face on camera when he decides to [__] talk someone.
That character is actively wearing an Ultimate Review helmet.
As he's saying that an impression is offensive. And I mean, when
I saw Anisa's clip, >> Absolutely disgust- Could you imagine
talking [__] about somebody's appearance when you
don't cam up yourself? That's actually so disgusting. I can't
imagine anybody wanting to do that. Holy >> The first thing
that I thought of was not what is H3H3 going to say about this.
Obviously, they're going to find it offensive. What I was thinking
was, "Huh, how is Nick DeOrio going to avoid covering this?"
Because I had no expectation
that this guy, who has a massive background in the commentary
community before becoming a shill for the clients, would openly
say on his stream that he found an impression of someone offensive.
>> Imagine going to xQc, and you're like, "Hey, dude, what
are you going to cover today?" Bro, THEY'RE JUST [__]
CRAZY. LITERALLY, SOMEBODY'S BEEN [__] with the situation.
They're like, "I got so much to say about- Like, what are what
are you expecting [__] xQc to say about JFK's assassination?"
>> As someone who grew up in Quebec, I found that deeply.
>> Dude, he actually somehow through time and space used
the same example I did, except it was a different quip aquah,
It was a different quip aquah, but it was a the same concept,
okay? I used Mama JF and her voice like this cuz it's closer
to Hila Klein. But, he found XQC, you love to see it, okay? >> offensive.
Okay, what the Nick, you
How dare you go after XQC? Don't you know it's his second language?
Sorry, guys. I forgot. The only people you're not allowed to
criticize are Israelis, apparently. How dare you do an impression
of a self-proclaimed IDF soldier who volunteered to go on to
a night raid into a terrorist city, as Ethan Klein would say.
>> So, I was a soldier. >> You told me once you went
on like a mission with them? >> To like a terrorist city?
>> That was kind of a crazy story. >> Yeah, the So,
the my officers and like the the soldiers in that brigade, um
they would go every night on a raid.
>> In Ramallah to to arrest terrorists. And um so, I always
saw them preparing for it and leaving. And then I I would stay
in the base. >> So, one time I wanted to go with them just
to experience it. >> I just I just wanted to I just wanted
to know. I wanted to experience raiding a terrorist city. I mean,
hell, she even looks like XQC in this one. We can't make fun
of both of them. It got so bad that he even had to release a
statement on Augie RFC's sub Reddit. Which, by the >> Clip
Live is the Augie RFC sub Reddit. That's true. That's very true.
It's so kind of Augie to provide mods to Nicholas Deorio on Augie
sub Reddit. >> Hey, between uh me and you, Augie, I know
how you feel about this stuff. Say something. Maybe Deorio's
been associating with the Kleins too much, but he's starting
>> hold on. Augie has said something. And all you have
to do is look at Augie's statements on this to understand where
he is, okay?
I'm not I'm not going to like I'm going to recall as best I can
from memory cuz I don't have the quotes, okay?
Augie has said something along the lines of, "Well, you know
what it is? Nicholas has got to get his bag. Nicholas is trying
to make like a business out of this and all that, right?"
Translation, yeah, he sold out and he's going to make money and
he just wants to retire. He wants to be retired at 30,
That's the translation. It's like, don't expect solid,
like unbiased critical analysis from Nicholas De Orio, right?
Don't Don't expect that.
He's just going to He's going to get his bag, okay? >> into
play their tactics. In the clip I'm about to show you, the H3
Podcast crew decide to spend 6 minutes trying to figure out if
smelling like pennies is an anti-Semitic joke. >> Tamara,
she creeps me out for real. >> She looks like she smells
like pennies,
>> I am sorry, but what the [__] is that? >> Well,
that I I that's what I wanted to say. This is what I This is
what I wanted to talk about. I cuz I thought about that. And
right away I was like,
>> Really went in on the
>> Why even risk
>> Like, you should not feel comfortable
How do I put this? There's probably something like this in the
past. You should not feel comfortable being this neurotic on
a stream. You should not feel comfortable just immediately like
say You shouldn't feel comfortable saying, "My first thought
was everybody else is racist against me."
You shouldn't feel comfortable saying that. It should require
a little bit of work to make the allegation, right?
Then it's like the first place your brain goes, "Well, they're
being anti-Semitic. Well, they're being anti-Semitic. Well, they're
being anti-Semitic."
You are a neurotic mess that needs to reevaluate how they look
at the world, okay?
Stop. Just stop. >> being misconstrued as anti-Semitic
for >> These folks misconstrue everything as anti-Semitic
all the time. That's like half of the content on the podcast.
But you know what's totally cool, totally kosher? Uh apparently,
going over Sneako's nudes, laughing about it. How dare you say
that one of the crewmates on the podcast smells like pennies?
Oh, by the way, we're going to laugh our asses off like this.
is going on with Sneako? >> What was that? >> That
was the gayest man alive. >> What the hell was that? >> What's
going on with Sneako? That's the gayest man alive. In response
to his nudes that were shared by Brandon Buckingham being leaked.
They can say whatever the [__] they want about whoever
the [__] they want, whenever they want. But you dare
say anything that they can
twist or misconstrue in their own way, they will twist it, and
they will spend 6 minutes telling you about it. >> And
you know what's crazy? She did this after
in her first stream, she had this story about how Ethan and I
show up late to the podcast and then leave right after, so we
have no soul. She said that we have no soul. >> Oh, well,
I'll pull that. I'll pull that. We got that. >> But but
people also pointed that that is
Is that Is it racist against gingers?
Bro, that's like saying um what it Was it Kevin? It was It was
the I can't remember his name. It was the guy from the Heritage
Foundation when he did his like um he said called some people
a venomous coalition. And then he had to end up apologizing for
venomous being anti-Semitic.
That's That's on that level right there. Uh they said I didn't
have a soul and I didn't think about how racist that was. Every
single thing is anti-Semitism,
>> Like making people seem inhumane
and and less than. >> You show up late to your podcast,
and I don't think you put any soul into your podcast. That's
racist. It gets to a point. Stop being a cry bully. I genuinely
think Deorio has just spent too much time watching their content
and supporting their ideas. Or worse, maybe he's always just
been like this. Hey Nick, are you a cry bully for money or is
this all for the love of the game? Nick Deorio's entire content
strategy for the past >> It's over. Breakdown. He's done.
It's over. He's mad. She lied. CPS bad. It's bad. It's bad.
They're past. He's mad. Still bad.
>> year has been siding with Ethan Klein on every possible
situation and belittling and on any
All I'm saying is Dickers asked me about a test for democracy.
Anybody who likes these videos or watches them to completion,
first people disenfranchised, okay? Get them away from the boat.
They are cattle. They should not be allowed to vote. That may
actually affect Democrats by the way. That might be bad, but
listen. They're going to end up being mind controlled by some
totally
psychotic in the future anyway, so we get them out now, okay?
Pain now for gain later, all right? >> thing. If they breathe
wrong, belittling everything that Ian and Anissa do. I mean,
I was watching this guy's vod last night and he's talking about
Anissa's how it's cheap and ugly. These people get comfortable
criticizing people's relationships, talking about how Idubz is
a in his relationship, how Anissa's the one wearing the pants.
And it made me think, I wonder I wonder about Nick Deorio's relationships.
You know, I've been around a long time in this whole commentary
thing and I remember I just remember seeing a tweet, something
that Nick Deorio posted. >> But Tonka, when did the tears
come out of my eyes? I was crying? >> When did the tears
come out of your eyes? Probably when that girl said she wasn't
your girlfriend on that post. That was the saddest [__]
I've ever >> What girl said she wasn't my girlfriend? >> When you
posted a picture of you holding somebody's hand, just trying
to be vague about it and then they're like, "You have a girlfriend?"
And the girl's like, "No, no, no, he's my best friend." >> Dude,
you have no idea what you're >> That was funny as [__]
>> It's hilarious. >> was funny as [__]
Okay, so that didn't happen, Nick. >> Nick, did that happen
or not? >> Yeah, it absolutely happened. >> You posted
a vague picture of you holding somebody's hand or like some [__]
and then the do you have a girlfriend? She's like no, no, no,
he's my best friend and not my girlfriend. >> about my
personal life on here. I >> It's not your personal life.
It's a tweet he made. It's a tweet you made, >> publicly.
I >> you made. That's not your personal life. It's a tweet
you made. >> I talk about my [__] personal
life? >> It's a tweet, not your personal life, >> Oh,
wow. You think it's cool to talk about like I I I intentionally
don't name [__]
>> Somebody Somebody sent me another
I ate Chud Logic and my tummy's still a grumbling. It's bad.
Huge belly.
The the fusion of Chud Logic and Nicholas DeOrio is horrifying.
I do not like this. Who Why would somebody do
Gross. Why would this happen? Why did this happen? >> people
like this, specifically cuz I keep that part of my life very
off the >> No, you don't. You try to post it and look cool
and you didn't look cool, >> It was her idea to make the
post in the first place. I told her I'm sure it was. That's none
of your business. >> Then why'd you post it on Twitter,
Nick? It's none of my business. Why is it up there, Nick? Why'd
you post it if it's none of anybody's business?
How is this your PERSONAL LIFE, NICK?
>> DEBATE TALKER. >> Because it's funny. >> Dude,
it's so crazy that he talks about his personal life, right? He
talks about his personal life. He makes tweets about the about
it and then he's like, "Dude, why would you bring that up on
a stream, on a live stream? Why would you bring that up on a
live stream?" >> Remember, we're talking about things that
are funny. We're debating
We're debating, Nick. Is that what's >> I can't believe
you. I'm out of here, >> OH, DID NICK
>> IF YOU'RE WONDERING what they're all laughing about
and DeOrio is getting extremely defensive about. It's this tweet.
D'Orio posts an image of him clinking glasses with what appears
to be a woman. Someone
>> Sleepy waiting found it. >> I guess you have a
girlfriend. The woman in question replies, "We aren't dating,
but he's my best friend." AND D'ORIO
>> AH,
IT HURTS. It hurts. It hurts a lot.
Oh my god.
>> D'Orio responds, "Shh, women." Any man that has ever
lived, okay, any man that has ever existed has been friend-zoned,
okay? That happens. It's a part of life. And 99% of the time
I would not be criticizing or making fun of somebody getting
friend-zoned. But with Nicholas D'Orio, there's something cosmically
beautiful about it. Nick makes most of his money by criticizing
and [__] on a couple that he just does not like.
Well, a couple that Ethan Klein does not like. And frankly, it's
a couple that despite all of the hate online that they've had
for years has been able to stick together. I'm not saying that
they're a great couple or a couple that I would model my relationship
after, but you got to give it to them. Despite all of the hate,
despite every single commentary YouTube channel, including my
own, making fun of them, they have stuck it out. And D'Orio
throughout this entire time has been a sad, lonely, single loser
larping that he has some sort of relationship on Twitter and
then getting called out in a debate in a Discord call. >> Dude,
you have no idea what you're >> That was funny as [__]
>> It's hilarious. >> No, that was funny as [__]
Okay, so
>> How old is video? I thought the Jumbos were divorcing.
Wait, what are you talking about, Canadian Collar? I feel like
I would have heard about that if that were actually happening.
I'm pretty sure that's not happening. Why are you spreading misinformation
in the chat? >> Didn't happen, man. Nick, did that happen
or not? >> Yeah, it absolutely happened. >> You posted
a vague picture of you holding somebody's hand or like [__]
some [__] and then they were like "Do you have a
girlfriend?" She's like "No, no, no, he's my best friend and
not my >> about my [__] personal life on here.
You know another question I asked was "Why don't you show your
face when
people?" You know, "Why don't you Why don't you put on a face
cam, grab a helmet that says Ultimate Review, and and actually
live the part a little bit?" You know, it takes a lot of the
oomph out of your bullying when you're hiding behind a little
wiggler. What are you afraid? You afraid >> I don't think
it does, but I respect what Chillepe's doing here. >> your
putrid malformed chins? Nick, you're a and you've gotten into
one of the best financial situations you could have ever dreamt
of, but all it cost was your [__] soul. Joe Rogan
should give Ela back her >> No, no, no, no, don't say you're
kidding. Every criticism Chillepe makes here applies to me as
much as it applies to Nicholas. Probably more. So I don't show
my face at all. >> What meds were you talking about there?
A horse do you want? >> Remember when you and the boys
were calling her a horse-faced
Did you switch cuz you found it offensive, Mr. Ultimate Rape
Review, or did you switch cuz the money's so
>> You call this just some charm? >> the ugliest
necklaces next to the ugliest tattoos from the ugliest
>> Yo, where's your face cam, Nick? Hey Nick, where's your
face cam?
>> Nick likes to talk about materialistic things. He's
a big fan of watches. He's criticizing Anisa's cheap necklace.
I also found out that he's got a pair of $600 glasses. I found
out about this cuz he was talking
>> Is he the half-baked stuff? >> about it. And >> By
the way, if Nick doesn't want people talking about his personal
life, why does he talk about his personal life? All the >> You
know, I I was with a girl once and I like Jesus, I >> So
this wasn't talked about beforehand,
and this was just something in the heat of the moment, and And
she just put her finger in my ass and I was like, "What the [__]
are you doing?" And then we just stopped. I was like, "What the
fuck?" I don't >> Very very Sorry, I had never seen this
guy's face before while he said it. I never seen this dude's
face before.
What Zito?
Zonya is not Zonya is having a thousand yards stare here. Okay,
okay, okay, all right, all right. Sartus is gone. Sartus has
left the
Boblox not really that put off, okay? Boblox is like, "Yeah,
you do what you do, bud." Awesome stuff. >> his story from
VidCon. Now, if you're not aware, Nick Diiorio has told this
VidCon story a couple of times. Once on his stream, uh once on
his podcast, and then a second time on his stream. Now, when
Nick tells you this story, he wants you to believe that some
flamboyant gay man confronted him over his coverage of Boblox.
That this pipsqueak had some funny-sounding voice. >> He's
like, "I don't like you." >> For the record, this is what
Net Loss sounds like. >> All right, I want to start off
by saying that I'm neither a capitalist nor am I not a capitalist.
>> I don't think Nick is very good at impressions here.
>> He's like, "I don't like you." And I'm like, "Oh, >> okay.
Like, so wait, what are you going to do about it?" He's like
And then I
>> And I just >> Oh, and then he did something about
it? >> Called him a slur.
I'm like, "You're acting like a slur right now." >> You
called him a slur. I thought that that that would be offensive,
wouldn't
>> So, he snatched my glasses off my face and started dancing
seductively at me. So, I followed him for like two seconds and
I realized he's not >> The funny thing Dude, it's actually
so funny to me now that Nick doesn't find any of that [__]
offensive. He thinks that [__] is funny. He's just
like Dude, he he just actually sold himself. Like, he actually
just sold himself.
Not cheaply, at least.
You know, not cheaply. But he just when he says it's offensive,
he that's not his opinion. He doesn't think that at all. He had
to come up with some ba-
half-baked rational ha half-baked rational after the fact, but
he just sold himself. He's just going to be the guy who's going
to go along with whatever they say and keep collecting
That's it. That's all. This is very obvious from everything that's
going on, right? He's not turning around. >> And then I
walked back.
>> Now, if somebody takes glasses off your face, what do
you do about it? Would you just call him a slur and let him walk
away with your glasses? Or you going to go get back your glasses?
>> Ah, they're prescription. You can have them back. I'm
like, "Yeah, thanks for my $600 glasses." I'm like, "Ah." >> Yeah,
but if you were if you were to go like take my glasses or he
did, then he's going to get smacked, bro. That's not my fault.
It's your fault. >> You got to understand, I'm in like
an aura right now. Like the >> Nick's buddy Vega would
smack someone to get his glasses back. But DeOrio himself, he'll
let you take his $600 glasses whenever you want. You want to
know why? Because Nick's a short, fat, little man. That's why
Nick hides behind the Wiggler. That's why his girlfriend friend-zoned
him when he posted a photo of their hands on Twitter. And that's
why when he was bullying his transgender friend Bo Blacks, when
Nick >> Dude, think about how crazy that is. That girl
was so offended by the implication that they were dating that
she doxxed herself to everybody just to be like, "No, no, that's
not happening. No, no, that's not happening. No, we're not dating.
No." She She literally gave up all pretense of like privacy.
She gave it all up just TO BE LIKE, "NO, NO, NO, NO, [laughter]
NO." THERE NOBODY COULD identify her. That's a picture of her
hand. Nobody knew who that was, and she had to be like, "Woah!
Holy fuck."
>> No, no. That's not happening, guys. That's like my best
friend. That's like my brother. He's kind of like my brother
in a way. >> That loss decided to come and take his $600
glasses off his face, he did absolutely nothing. He's a sad,
pathetic little man. Let me be clear. Little little this way,
not >> Now now it's it's never been clear to me that we
need the Nick version of this meme, okay? We need the Nick version
of this meme right now, okay? I need the Nicholas DeOrio version
of this meme to be created. I don't know what powers will have
to be wielded to make that happen, but I do need it, okay?
Look at the This could be us. Look how happy you look. And then
you have to make it so his head comes up to your her eyes,
He's like Nicholas is perfectly square. All right, and his head
comes up to her
Could be us. Look how happy you look. Look how happy you are.
Is this AI? Yeah, if you missed this earlier, this woman freaked
out cuz some dude AI'd a photo of them like in a bathroom taking
a picture together and sent it to her in
>> Dude, it's so crazy. Dude, it's actually nuts, all right.
I need it though. I need it. >> Not little this way.
>> Oh, [__]
>> pathetic, little man. Let me be clear. Little little
this way, not not little this way.
>> Here it is. Here it is. Here it is. Right here.
Apparently this is Yeah, Nicholas is not tall, okay? Nicholas
is not a tall guy.
He's a short little guy. Just a short little guy. Who are these
people? I don't know I know who the main guys are. I know Nick,
Tom, BoBlocks, Augie. Oh, that must Is that Connor?
That doesn't look like Connor. I don't think that is.
I don't know who the other guys are. Wow. Okay.
Now, I had something else that's going to Hold on, we have other
stuff we wanted to add to this. Give me a second. It was Oh,
we went through the tweet and some of the responses, okay?
Tactical Templar video coming out. He's going in on Nicholas
DeOrio. Did he make Nicholas fatter in this? Is this like Photoshop
to make Nicholas fatter in this thumbnail?
Why would you do this?
Hold on, I'm being told that apparently this reaction to the
next the next Anisa video. Damn.
>> Business business. >> Dude, this is business with
Dude, holy
So, I think they call that I really like they call that not business,
right? Like this is this is like this is stripper if if this
is business, this is like your job is being a stripper at like
a >> Bro, I'm I'm sorry. Hit Anisa on like any other thing.
Dude, Anisa
Anisa is hot and and if you can't admit that Anisa is hot, if
you got to like try to deride her on that
I feel like you got you got crazy like energy. Like I I don't
know I don't know what you're doing. What what's the goal?
>> actually like did a wing. Look at her. >> Yeah,
dude, if your business is stripping at like a >> Anisa
is mid at best, sorry. >> Anisa is like
How do I put She's like Oh, I was going to say she's like Piccolo.
She's like intentionally putting getting like the trashiest tattoos
to make herself seem less hot
because she's like working with such an advantage, okay?
It's just balance.
>> a place where successful people are, then yeah, this
is business. >> I'm so 2016
>> This looks like you're doing business as you're like
role play like your floor play. >> I have like the >> Like
you guys are like oh, I'm going to be a business woman tonight.
Is that how jobless people have
They're like oh, let's let's uh let's put on costumes tonight.
Let's be let's let's experiment.
Is that how jobless people have
Why is he One, why is he even speculating? Why would he even
be speculating to begin with?
And then why would you think that's actually something people
with jobs do, okay? Jobless people just all the time. They're
just all the time. People without jobs are like, well, we have
to make this worth it cuz we are too busy. We can't [__]
it up. So, we have to make this worth it.
Yeah. No, this is actually something people with jobs do. >> It's
like, oh, I'm going to pretend that I'm employed. >> Aggressive
way >> I'm going to be employed tonight.
Dallas put it in the Ela Klein accent. I will say >> Guys,
for my my Halloween costume is going to be a employed person.
>> I was not expecting that to go All right, can you hear
me? I was not expecting that >> Yeah, dude. Your your role-play
>> to go viral. Now, it's blocking my excellent cleavage.
Nobody wants that. >> But, it brought me great >> Except
for you in the past. >> joy. Which clip me doing my Ela
I thought you were I thought you did like being on camera.
>> Ed, I think what it proves to >> This is going
to be awesome because I would love to watch the Tactical Templar
react to this cuz I feel like Nick is going to do a Tactical
Templar-like
But, then how would Templar Tactical Templar react to the Nick
skin walk of Tactical Templar?
These are like two of the same people at different stages in
life, okay? One of them found YouTube early, found the miracle
path to success, but they are really very similar people. >> to
me is that my irrelevancy was a
>> I feel like she used that line already. Did she rehearse
this?
Didn't we just watch a clip where she just said that, but she
was with iDubbz?
>> Oh, is is Nick going to start hitting people for repeating
the same story or the same quote or the same joke? Cuz there's
nobody who does that more than this Yes. Nobody's Nobody does
that [__] more than Nicholas. I've listened to Nicholas
say the same joke eight different times between eight different
stream appearances. This guy recycles jokes more than anybody
I've ever met. There's no shot he's going to hit her for recycling
the same statement twice. >> Was she How long was she thinking
about >> Even the haters had used to think he was
Uh he is funny in that he can laugh at himself and make it funny.
He's got that going for him. But now, unfortunately, too many
of his patterns are too lazily applied over and over again. It's
become less funny to me over time.
Right? Like it's you know exactly the way he's going to try to
make jokes. And when he's actually trying to snark, he is weak
as >> had to admit it was good. No, you know what though?
You know >> Wait, what?
All right, is this the same clip?
>> Okay, I'll play the music. Let me just get into the
It's hard
to do it all. >> Is this two different clips?
Canadian [snorts] girls rock denim like >> This is not
the same clip and this is the beginning of the stream, I think.
Okay, I guess we'll watch both. Who Thank you Empathy Enjoyer
or Josie. >> and admit it was good.
was um Nicholas DeOrio. He like didn't want to come to terms
with it. He's like having to fake >> Nicholas DeOrio is
Dude,
how badly are we winning everything?
Listen, all these people needed
All these people Listen, Anisa, iDubbz, they're too busy in real
life, okay? We'll just give them the script for how to clap.
We'll just give them the script for what they should say, okay?
She just will A couple tweets will appear and they'll be like
that they'll run with the right narrative, the right thing to
say, and it's going to be awesome. It's going to be great. >> face
the nightmare, which is his pay pig is like dying. It's like
they're on their dying breath. Nobody gives a
I'm actually losing it right now. Is she saying that my Okay,
people were telling me that she said that my channel was
Is she saying that a 20,000 concurrent viewer live show is dying?
Have you looked at you and your husband's numbers?
If you brought in a thousand unemployed >> They could literally
retire from the internet and it wouldn't change why How is that
not just what aboutism?
>> You say [clears throat] You say that's that show is
dying. Well, have you Have you seen how bad your career is doing?
Okay. Like that Why is that relevant?
Why is how well they're doing
relevant to if the H3 podcast were
>> dude. Wait. Are you You're talking about the H3 podcast?
>> is a anymore. Ethan and Ian >> Wait. What? >> their
show is turning into like regurgitated Slop Tuber content. >> My
numbers are exactly the same as they were before. >> about
me and Ian. That's all they have. And I love it. >> I'm
up from last month.
>> I have to tell you I'm having the time >> Wait.
What is she talking about?
>> of my life because the more they 4 hours he talked about
me. 4 hours. No one cares, dude. No one cares. >> I think
that video got like a one out of It was a It was >> Nicholas,
the goat. I'm looking at my Oh, people do care. She's wrong on
that. People do care.
But unfortunately for Nick, he I Maybe he just can't see that
it's starting to flip. Again, this is the problem with having
nobody in your audience who has like a like an internal monologue,
right? If you've got nobody in your audience who can ever go,
"Oh wait. Um have you seen that like you know, people are starting
to flip on this that they don't really think Ethan's quite as
cool as before. He's He's struggling to maintain relevance.
Um people actually are starting to like think Anisa's funny."
No. No, he's got none of those people. He's just got a bunch
of drones who are like, "Huh. Anisa streamed again. Here's some
[__] she said." That's all they're going to do. >> I
love my man. >> Today I uploaded a video on Anisa. It's
a four out of 10, but I'm streaming over myself, and it's trailing
my three out of 10 by by is that 400 views?
And then it's trailing my two out of 10 by like 600 views. If
I wasn't streaming today, this would be a two out of 10 video.
And funny enough,
the video that's on the top is Anisa Jomha. Yeah, this is beating
out my Anisa video.
>> It is killing the channel. Nicholas is losing people
to the queen. Poetic
>> It was only a matter of time. >> channel was dying.
Here's some empathy. >> Dude, it's so You guys DID IT SO
FAST. WHAT THE
DUDE, YOU GUYS DID IT SO FAST.
This could be us.
Look how happy you look.
Always over 4,000. Some nights we dip in our max dips under 3,000
now. But I'm >> [__] Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Is he talking about his own stream? What happened
to his What happened to his viewers? >> We actually have
dropped a couple, and that's because on most nights I'm competing
directly with Ethan now. Like Ethan's channel Like we were we
were almost always over 4,000. Some nights we dip in our our
max dips under 3,000 now. But I'm competing directly with Ethan's
channel.
There's a 4,000 viewer podcast in my way
>> I'm I don't >> He's talking about like Harley
and Glam.
>> Okay. That just tells you what kind of drones watch
this, right? If you're losing out to Glam, bro, that show is
He's about to get his lunch taken by Glam. Oh, no.
Oh, no. Harley and Glam going to take this guy's lunch.
>> I don't know. Don't you get sick of what looking at
the dude the war again? >> Dude, he launched another show.
>> I Although I guess that's why he has the little animated
avatar, right? During is back. It is.
At least I have the balls to show my face when I'm talking. Who
um Nick >> Bro, I don't Dude, listen. If I did that, I
would have everyone being like, "Did he just shower? Or did he
just Or is his hair greasy like your husband?" Dude, the time
that it would take to have to set up a camera and do all that
like other editing and [__] like that. It's so easy
to just log in, have nothing to do. Just I don't even have to
like look around or or or >> Why is he coping?
Hold on. Let's go back Let's go back. I have to listen to the
cope a little bit >> 4,000 viewer podcast. >> No,
no, no. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. >> to show my face when
I'm talking. Who um >> Bro, I don't Dude, listen. If I
did that, I would have everyone being like, "Did he just shower?
Or did he just Or is his hair greasy like your husband?" Dude,
the time that it would take to have to set up a camera and do
all that like other editing and [__] like that. It's
so easy to just log in, have nothing to do. Just I don't even
have to like look around or or or care about
Hold on. And doesn't this guy work? Does he not have to hop on
calls for work at all? Or >> I I could do literally anything.
I could be texting one in the middle of a segment. You guys wouldn't
know. It is so optimized to the point where everything that I
do on here is as little effort as humanly possible. >> me
viciously on Twitter. >> Thank you. If we do panel streams,
I'll be on camera, but until then, everything that I do is optimized
to do as little effort as humanly possible. It's the like running
the channel on [__]
>> Ego check. Does Nick have more Twitch >> No way.
There's no way I do. We haven't pushed the Twitch in a while.
>> Plus D'orio aka epic >> I'm a mister
Oh wait, dude. Wait, hold on. hold on. This is This is a [__]
I can hear it. I can smell a donation clip. Please call me mister
man or mister reviewer man, please. All still >> And so
funny that he um I I assume he watched some of the Trisha Paytas
stuff, right? Or watched looked at the tweets. This isn't a prediction
when you already know that she looked at the same tweets you
did. >> Show my face when I'm talking. >> Who um
Nicholas Diorio aka Epic Review? What's Ronnie Weasley?
>> That's not a
Oh, is he just like pre-watching all of his stuff and then faking
predictions, dude.
Shit's dire out here, guys. You just got to like pre-watch all
the [__] and then try to make predictions.
>> It's dire out here. >> I'm sorry your channel
is dying. >> Yes, thank you. >> Everyone, pay him
now. >> I appreciate it. Oh, dude, she cut herself off.
I have to do a little a little ma This is The best part about
my Dobby Wednesday is when I make predictions, I'm usually doing
it on stuff that like literally came out or was getting streamed
like while I was live. All right? That's That's the real [__]
all right? Not taking [__] from 2 days ago and and
pre-watching and then trying to do predictions based off of that.
Then oh MY GOD, YES, DUDE. YES, DUDE. LET'S GO.
GOD, it's it's tragic. It's tragic to listen to. >> face
when I'm talking. >> Dude, mister man. >> Who um
Nicholas Diorio aka Epic Review? What's What's the name of his
Wait, is she going to say it?
>> Hold on, wait, is she going to call it ultimate review?
She's not going to call it review, right? That'd be [__]
up. >> Uh channel review
Ultimate review, I THINK. >> YES, DUDE. >> A PERSON.
WHO IS BUNNY KING? >> OH MY GOD, this is so awesome. >> Sorry,
I can't help but see a porn >> Oh my god, I [__]
love this. This is by the way, if you ever need a good window
into why democracy will fail, why democracy has failed, why democracy
can't work, it's just the fact that
this stream that Nicholas could actually be like a I I do believe
he once had the capacity to be an entertaining content
but it's it's actually just way more profitable to be what he
is now. Very sad. >> We all know THE DRILL.
GO! [screaming] >> THINK. YEAH. OH, NO, I'll tell you.
So, there's this creature
named Nicholas DeOrio. And Nicholas >> This is awesome.
is
someone who posts videos of him celebrating his birthday alone.
Which again, >> When did I do that? >> Not a problem,
but if >> Wait, when the [__] DID I DO THAT?
>> If you're you know, I don't know, maybe friend and family
deficient, at least have a dog or a cat >> I am three.
>> the best commentator of THE YEAR. >> WAIT, WHAT?
>> at or something. >> Dude, is she just Is she just
Oh, no.
this is This is rough as somebody who streams most nights by
themselves, okay? What the [__] Anissa? Collateral
damage, Anissa? What the [__]
>> He doesn't really strike me as a >> We didn't
even Wait, do you guys think Nicholas lives by himself?
Do you think he
There's no way Nicholas lives with like his parents, right?
What do you think?
Do you think he lives by himself? The I
>> I'm going to do a birthday stream. >> Cat guy.
Celebrate the birthday of your birthday with a cat, dude. But
he doesn't even have that. >> Wait, I literally dude, >> Nicholas
tweet on Nicholas DeOrio. >> Wait, people appreciate >> The crazy
part is >> Hi Anissa. Hope you enjoy >> Uh my mom
wished me a happy birthday this morning, Anissa. Excuse me, Anissa.
My My and dad wished me a happy birthday, and then we had a special
dinner tonight, okay, Anissa? Don't say I'm alone. I'm not alone.
>> giving Nick money rather than funding your sad, cold
life. >> We had like a >> eggs dwindle faster.
>> I don't even think that's actually true. >> Keemstar
orbiter, Nick Oreo. >> Wait, was that a Wait, the part
is was that a an egg check tweet? Hi, Anissa. Hope you enjoy
me giving Nick Oreo money Nick Oreo money rather than funding
your sad, cold life. Hope your eggs DWINDLE FASTER. DUDE,
THAT'S A THAT'S A COOL DONO. THAT'S A COOL DONO. >> HI,
ANISSA. Hope you enjoy >> We got the
We got the egg timer.
Classic egg timer to egg timer dono. Let's go. Molly meme posting
for sure. >> funding your sad, cold life. >> What
do you mean you don't even think that's true? We had like a >> eggs
dwindle faster.
>> I don't even think that's actually true. >> Keemstar
orbiter, Nick Oreo, Mr. Oreo.
>> Wait, what is this?
What What is What is this symbol? 6990
Cuz I know what I would immediately think that is, but I I don't
know off the top of my head actually. >> Shalom UJR comes
to the rescue. >> Never mind, it's very obvious what it
>> rescue of your dead channel.
>> Bro, he's getting checks and he's not even sucking that
hard, guys. >> [__] snowstorm. I don't even
think I was alone that time of the year.
>> Watching Anissa's stream live feels like watching animals
at the zoo. Anyways, have more money, broke man.
>> Bro, you're dissing Sophie right now, my
DON'T YOU STOP LYING? PLEASE STOP LYING. WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?
LIKE EVERY SINGLE THING IN THIS VIDEO YOU KNOW YOUR VIDEO IS
A LIE. >> OH [screaming] MY NO.
OH MY GOD.
WHAT? THAT. Oh my god, I just figured >> I'm sorry you're
poor and have zero friends and your dog >> no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. >> This is why I told you guys this
stream is literally unwatchable.
This stream is literally unwatchable.
Dude, oh my god. >> wait, someone in chat just pointed
out what she's probably talking about. >> last night and
after watching that stream, I'm kind of [__] black
pilled on this [__] >> Dude, dude, dude, dude.
>> to welfare, here's my hard earned cash to keep your
after paying 40 20 pinball machines. Fun fact, the only other
person that I have heard say smell pennies is Sam Hyde. >> Oh,
they're going to start doing the pennies thing again? No way.
No way.
There it is. This could be us. Look how happy you look.
>> Oh boy.
That could be them. That could be them.
>> Can I say something to >> I think I know what
she's talking about. >> That is exactly what we wanted
right there. That is it.
>> All right, all right, look. >> Link it. I did
link it. Did I not? Hold on, I'll put it in the chat. >> 2000
and one. >> tweet, juicy tweet.
>> Oh, is he going to Ethan Ralph now? Nope, he's doing
something. >> This is like my >> So, if somebody
reached out to me and sent me some stuff. >> Oh god, this
is a stowaway. This is like my second video ever. >> And
looking at that information, it's kind of like, I don't know.
Having your cake. >> Can I say something to you, Nick?
I really like you.
>> And you mean it, too. >> Did she think this was
my birthday?
This was a bad bit in a video in 2018.
What is this actually my Ethan Ralph video? The intro of this
goes hard.
>> And we'll have more. >> What a great, what a great
clarification, Nick. Thank you. >> Say later. I'm sure
>> Uh, there's a lot out there on you, buddy, so we'll
see what happens. But, I just wanted to show once and for all
that I'm not actually [clears throat] 5 ft 1. >> That's
for the Ralph video. Did she think that that was my birthday?
I don't know. How old were you then? Probably >> I ALWAYS
DO THE POSSIBLE. >> UH BUT ANYWAYS, he is a commentary
one of these >> His mugshot does say 5 ft 10. >> [__] cowards
are crazy. >> It does not. >> The new one? >> Can
I say something to you, Nick? I really like you. >> It's
commentary slot, guys. >> And he has this >> Your
voice sounded different. That's the Blue Yeti. I'm on the um
I'm on the the Shure SM7 Rogan now.
>> segment. I've heard whis- >> That's a joke, right?
That has to be a joke. That has to be a joke. He's just memeing
on Hasan. He has to be. That's definitely a joke, just memeing
on Hasan. There's no way There's no way.
>> Cuz there's no way I would sit through a whole hour.
How >> Bro, she literally admitted that she watched my
stream the other day, and now she's heard whispers of it. >> How
long does he stream for? She heard
>> SHE HEARD CHINESE WHISPERS.
>> HE STREAMS FOR A WHILE. Um but he has this segment called
the ultimate rip review, where he reviews
uh rip cases and decides
>> I'm trying my best, okay? I'm trying my best to make
some content happen.
>> Can I say something to you, Nick? He's talked about
the Yeti before.
Bro, I had a Blue Yeti. My voice didn't sound that Your voice
doesn't sound that
Your voice does not sound that
That's a cope.
This is probably the best This was my best financial decision
ever was to was to host ultimate rip review.
I don't think we've done one of these like actual named streams.
It has It has been my best financial decision in history. >> ment
called the ult- >> People ask, if you can go back back
in time and not host ult- You sounded so different. I sound different
cuz I stream more and I know how to talk now.
I talk with a little oomph to the voice, okay? Instead of just
reading things in a monotone all the time.
Like that's the only That's the difference is I just have like
a personality now, okay? I like literally learned how to talk
so it could be entertaining for you guys so you don't fall asleep.
That's all. Ultimate Review. I'd be like, "What are you talking
about?" >> Ultimate Review where he reviews
uh cases and destroys >> Can you just get it right? I don't
review cases. I review Ultimate cases. It's like Ultimate Frisbee.
It's like a different thing. >> decides whether or not
um the woman is
>> And we have the funny meter where we do >> Bruce.
And that's >> You did a Turkey Tom URR. That was true.
We did a Turkey Tom URR. >> by the way who Ethan and Ela
watch and enjoy. They think he has really good >> Dude,
Ethan loves Ultimate Review. He's watched every single episode.
Quoted directly from Ela with that. >> So um that's that's
>> Billy Mitchell and Chat Anisa and I are the gifts that
keep on giving. Hell yes, dude. Especially when you use code
Nick on Ricky's hot sauce. >> who that is. >> Can
I say something to you, Nick? >> It's vile. >> Ela
said yeah, Ela said that he's her favorite and uh she donates
to this uh >> Ela sent me a super chat?
This is so it's so um how how do I put
Wrong tactics. But Anisa will get there, okay? Anisa is like
clay that can be molded into a great streamer. I promise,
She just doesn't get it. You don't You don't do this this play
to people's like emotions or people's I guess um sensibilities
doesn't work anymore,
When you're like, "Oh, well, he he does this bad thing." And
and Ethan really likes this guy who does this. That doesn't work
for anyone, okay?
But don't worry.
She'll get it. She'll get it.
>> It had to be a year ago. >> She's still learning,
okay? She took some time off of streaming. She's going to get
her feet under her. She's just learning. Listen, all we needed
to know about her potential is that Ela Klein impression, okay?
That's all we needed to know. That was >> It was >> So
she read a snark thread and went all dude, I've got all the information
I need to go in on this [__] guy. >> And if
you look at him like a picture of him, he doesn't like stream
himself.
Which I
>> Thank you. >> What he looks like I get. Because
he looks like he should be holding a giant
oversized lollipop at all times. >> Jesus Christ.
That's also an image that I want. That's also an image that would
be very funny.
Nicholas Deorio, can we get Nicholas Deorio Oompa Loompas? All
different they're members of the lollipop guild,
>> By the way, the issue that she has here >> yourself
Kefals squeak. >> Oh my god, we keep getting donations.
This is the actual URL. Holy
Thank you. >> you lied to us about having dogs. Whose dogs
did you even show us? >> Dude, I showed you I stole those
dogs. They're not even legally mine, bro.
The thing is Anissa is the one with like crippling self-image
problems. That's kind of her jam. So I mean, swing away. >> I
get it. I think he also lied about having a girlfriend and then
got outed >> No lying.
do the roar. >> Do the do the roar, Kevin. >> Dude,
we're still doing the fake girlfriend energy.
>> Send it to Twitch just so Nick can brag about having
a channel he doesn't use has more subs than her. >> Oh
my god. Dude, you >> I don't need my chat promoting my
dead Twitch. They're going to think it's [__] money
laundering. >> has no dogs. He's felt it. He has no >> I'm
dogless. >> Honeybee honeybee honeybee.
>> We have those images from Massage Kitty after you called
him the mind guy. I've seen them on Twitter. Oh, I didn't even
know that. >> So I yeah. And he's talking >> insulting
me viciously on Twitter.
>> Bro, I don't know how I legitimately don't know how
people do >> I didn't see this 3 days >> Like I get
By the way, I don't even blame Nick for this. I would I would
totally absorb all of these donations and take money for them,
Like he's not getting little amounts of money. He's getting like
10, 20, 30
per dono.
I totally get why he does it. It's so unwatchable as a viewer.
That's the crazy thing. >> go. Not I don't know whether
or not I'm
ugly, like really ugly or really good-looking because
>> YouTube people, people who make YouTube videos on me
and random people on the internet tell me that I'm ugly all the
time. But
really, really hot women
tell me that I'm pretty. >> Yorio, commentator of the year,
the best comedy duo of the year. >> Thank you. >> So,
I just don't >> Er is a failure. This donation is sent
on behalf of Anissa's close friend Hila
>> I don't know. I don't know which one it is. >> Is
Nick still a virgin?
Well, only if you don't count him being like anally as losing
his virginity.
Technically, if you count him being anally as losing his virginity,
you might say he's not a virgin anymore. >> Women like
look like models all the time. Just like they walk and they look
They can film a Tik Tok. I look like I'm afraid to bump into
myself. I [laughter] look like a baby foal that just fell out
of her mother's womb.
I look gross. I wish I thought I was hot. Not like I wish I was
hot.
>> So, he just I By the way, I was like a little bit, you
know, I was a little resentful to just, you know, platform all
this snark stuff,
But now that I see Ni- Nicholas Yorio just goes to the iDubbz
snark subreddit, pulls up clips from that Like listen, I I seems
like everything's on the table, right? Seems like it's all good.
>> It's like I don't know. Even if I was hot, I don't think
that I would think that I was hot. I wish that I thought that
I was hot. I feel like you can just
>> You can, to be clear. You can. >> talked about
us for a long time.
Um and I didn't >> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I am
going to cut this cuz we are we are >> Next, I just want
to say we love our legs. Everyone in chat, if you also love legs,
please spam chat with legs. >> Please don't spam chat with
legs. No, it's not sponsored by legs. Thank you. Thank you. >> so
many of these
but two, I I also just feel bad for him. I think out of all the
slop tubers, I feel the worst for him because I I yeah. Not good.
>> Cuz of him, it looks like he's not comfortable wearing
his own skin. So, I you know. >> Classic Anisa projection.
>> I'm done being nice, aren't we? >> Thank you.
>> Here's to the 4,000 concurrent viewers. That makes her
super viral.
>> Anisa's viral at 250 viewers. Go buy a victory watch.
He's making >> I think she's just talking about the >> bank
off of you. It's He's making bank off of Ethan and Hila. I There's
quite the talent of
people in that world. >> I think she is saying you need
to stream proper like she does and show your face and wear a
low-cut t-shirt. >> I swear to god, the more I watch something
like this, the more I'm like, "Actually, wait, maybe I do love
Ethan >> Dude, these people donate Guys, if you like the
content, you need to donate to the stream. Give subs. Donate,
okay? What the [__] I've watched this guy make 200
bucks in the time I've made
Okay, what the [__]
I'm about to start I'm about to start really liking Ethan Klein,
okay?
My god.
I'm going to chop Thank you for the one Thank you for the one
penny. Thank you for the singular penny. That was more than $200.
Thank you, Sophia. That was the correction I needed. That was
more than 200 That wasn't just $200. That was way more than $200.
[laughter]
>> Like that
There's two things that happened right now. One, if you and iDubbz
quit
or two >> The Oreo commentator of the year, the best He
has like 10x the viewers though.
I don't give a [__] if he has 10x the
I don't give a >> commentator of the year
Thank you.
If you and Ian quit streaming, I would
>> Let's go. BlackBeltLife gifted me gifted subs. Let's
go. Critical Rat, thank you for the gifted sub. I appreciate
it, >> significantly more money
than if Ian stopped talking about drama. That's just a fact.
Like the iDubbz and Anisa segments
>> Uh Deorio privated his Instagram. What? Weasel the Liar
dude, thank you for the gifted sub.
He privated his Instagram. What is this? What's going on here?
Nicholas Deorio has now privated his Instagram, which was once
public. Dude, I knew a guy I knew a guy with Nick's dimensions
who played hockey. I don't know how good a skater Nick is. Dude,
I've seen guys Nick's dimensions
who can skate like the wind and it's crazy. This is one guy I
knew, okay? Who could skate He was like He was so agile. It was
It was like a hippo on It was like a hippo ballerina, okay?
I If Nick was like that, I dude, we should find video of him
playing before.
I knew somebody like this when I played hockey who was like that
size and just It was crazy. Jesus, that's not what I'm looking
for. I'm looking for the tweet. Did I pull the tweet over? What
did I do with this? Where's the gamma tweet? Here it is. Yeah,
okay, he privated his Instagram and then there was right below
this Tactical Templar. LMAO,
this is a good night. Nick the Oreo friend zoned, dude. You're
getting snarked on by Tactical Templar.
You're getting snarked on by Tactical Templar of all people,
bro.
It's It's over.
I'm going to close this. We'll watch There's one more clip from
that I wanted to watch, but I can watch it after, >> Make
a killing, and they don't require Ethan responding to them. Finding
something >> Like we don't cover every Ethan Klein drama
he's doing. >> One who's just a little bit dumber than
you, so you can >> prey on them. >> Jesus, what the
What is this? What the hell? Womp glorp.
You any And you know what else is massive? Dude, why
Bro, why are people making these? That's That's crazy.
That's just a wild thing to do. >> But Nicholas Deorio
is getting hit by his own. I heard that he's becoming a lolcow
himself, so >> And that's the fate, isn't it, of those
creatures? He's making bank. How many people watch that content?
I think he gets like 4,000 viewers on average. >> Yep.
Yes.
>> But that's what I wanted to share with you guys next,
okay? Wait, is it illegal to share your wishes, guys? >> Oh
my god, Jesus Christ. >> You get in trouble for that? Is
that Will I go to jail if I share my wish? >> There's like
six donation sounds that can come out of this. I have to be really
picky. >> Because me
Plus it's like no. So, uh me and Ian had a rotisserie >> Holy
Epic black Oh, Epic bacon blackface. Thank you. >> also
said after working out and it's illegal not to. rotisserie chicken
after working out. And I found the wishbone, and I was like,
"Oh my god, we should do a wishbone with >> Tell me that
they tell me they broke a wishbone and they wished that my viewers
would dwindle like her eggs. Please, please tell me they DID
THAT.
NICK DEORIO EGG POSTING NOW. Oh my god.
Bro, he's molly memeing it up. I did not expect that. That is
like sort of the
That's the creme de la creme of like incel comments is when you're
like, "Your Your eggs are going away. Your eggs are going away."
I'm shocked he would do that. That was very funny.
Well, I I personally think that's hilarious.
I personally think that's hilarious. I do wonder
what the H3 crew thinks about that kind of thing, okay? That's
That seems very very very problematic
to those guys. Do you see how when I don't personally find it
offensive, but I think other people would find it offensive,
I point that out cuz I'm not a re-
See how that works? >> And please tell me they put like
a gypsy curse on my channel. >> So, we both made a wish
and we pulled on the bone and I won. >> My eggs are dwindling.
>> Thank you. >> Tell me right now. >> Antonio
Rey. >> Tell me that they've moved to a higher power to
try to stop my channel's >> Subscribing.
Uh it wasn't from Costco or Superstore. It was >> Please
stop interrupting her. Something funny could be happening here.
>> Um Safeway. And I wished for an average of a thousand
viewers a stream.
And I pulled that >> Oh, it's for her. Wrap >> that
thing and I got the majority. So, if magic is real >> To be
clear though, in comparison to your husband, you still probably
have the majority. >> In the next 3 months, I'll get an
average of a thousand viewers per stream. If magic is real. If
it's not real, well,
what's the point? >> Do you got to talk to Casey Tron and
she'll put in a good word with the
>> Jeriah would drag his balls over glass because he thought
Anissa would let him hit. I think Nick is like so self-conscious
around women. He's more like the kind of guy that would like
he would be too self-conscious to hit even if she wanted it.
You know what I'm saying? He'd be like, "No, I can't. I'm like
sick right now. I'm like a No, I couldn't I couldn't I could
I couldn't buy That's the kind of guy Nick is, okay? He just
wouldn't He wouldn't let it happen. He'd think he's getting He'd
think he's getting baited or something and he would not even
try. >> A shaman for you? >> Yeah, that's >> Oh,
wait, what? >> I support it. I support it. >> I missed
his whole thing with him uh I missed his whole thing with him
pointing out her like body image issues, right? I must have missed
that. >> Uh but now I'm going >> Somebody told me,
"Oh, this is a really funny comedy. Make don't miss it." And
then I must have missed it. >> going to pee >> I'm
guessing that was back when he watches the uh the start clip,
right? I must have missed it back here when he's watching like
her say that she's not sure if she's attractive anymore or
>> Whoa, class. >> Oh, dude, I saw the other one.
It's that >> Hold on. I do think he watches like the Twitter
clip. Maybe there's a little bit more here. >> This clip.
>> the goat >> Thank you for the $5 for that. >> charge
your crystals with USB-C? Yeah. >> Like no other. I know
I need to have like a full denim fit. My eggs are >> Obesity.
WHAT? >> YES, DUDE. BEST CHATTER. DUDE, THE BEST chatter
is locked in. >> Welcome to the salad boys.
>> Nick, your streams aren't un >> listed. They were
unlisted when I started. Maybe they published after. >> Okay,
let me go. >> But we have the clip now, so we don't need
it. >> on Nicholas DeOrio >> Cat farts appreciated
the shout-out. >> Dude, Obi is my favorite chatter.
I think this is the same clip. It's not. No, it's definitely
not the same clip. >> tell you guys something. I'll tell
you a little secret. >> ask for >> Love your makeup
today. Thank you. Oh my god, yeah. I just realized I ACTUALLY
>> OH, NO. WHAT AM I GOING TO DO? >> THANK YOU. >> It's
leg day, leg, leg, leg, leg, leg, leg, leg, leg, leg. [laughter]
>> How does it feel to be a lolcow who celebrates his birthday
alone? >> He could have milked that so much harder. Big
content strategy. >> thing I'm going to do is uh is maximize
your money, all right? >> is release >> How does
it feel to be a lolcow who celebrates his birthday alone? >> Dude,
the next thing I'm going to do is
I I was going [clears throat] to make an Ethan Ralph thing, but
I don't want to say that I'm going to [__] >> Unfortunately,
because I started a little bit late today, I this is something
I'm going to continue on with. But I just have to point it out
again
how much it sucks hearing donations this >> or whatever.
But ironically or I'll get >> Not because I'm jealous,
although I am jealous, okay? But, because it's unlistenable to.
Like, if you were Imagine trying to listen to this like in the
background or something. I But, I'm not dimin- I'm not diminishing
how jealous I am. I'm incredibly jealous of the amount of money
he makes, okay? But, on top of that, it's also just unlistenable
to.
>> Did a wing. Look at I'm so 2016.
>> Dude, the fun- Being a lolcow in 2026 is awesome. You
can either post revenge die in a Ukrainian prison, join a podcast
and make a of money while degrading yourself constantly, or um
shots fired at Harley? What the [__]
>> The first thing I thought here is, "Whoa, you're going
real hard on the over there, bitch." >> Whatever Bowblax
is doing. You have so many options these days. >> Stowing
it. >> There's so many avenues of failure.
>> I have like the aggressive wing and
>> You can become Cyra- I don't know enough about Cyrax.
>> Can I say something to you, Nick? I really like you.
>> Thank you. >> With the Ethan Klein accent. I will
say
Oh, yeah, I need to figure that out. Play music, but I can't
hear it, so I can focus. I
is this like your fifth stream so far? She hasn't figured out
the music thing. >> I'm sure my husband can help me.
>> Okay, I'll give you the answer. This is how you do it.
You literally just need to put the music on, have a playlist
of approved songs, and if you don't want to hear it, cuz I I
assume that your issue is it's like the way that people don't
want to hear themselves when they're podcasting, and that would
trigger the hell out of me if I could hear myself. Then, just
put it on a channel that you can't hear, but the stream can.
That's literally the solution to your problem. >> Um I
I will say
>> She doesn't understand channels. Like, that's that's
that's the solution. You can do that immediately. >> I
was not expecting that to go viral. Can you hear me? I was not
expecting that clip to go
Now it's blocking my excellent cleavage. >> Okay, this
is the same clip. Is there anything at the end here? >> What?
The same >> That's what I wanted to share with you
>> It's a wishbone clip.
>> Wait, is it illegal to share your
>> for an average of a thousand viewers a
>> Oop. Thank you for the $5, my man.
Come on. I think that's pretty sick. >> Hold on. Hold up.
Was that the Anisa clip? We've been talking about now Ah, it
was not. Did the Anisa clip come out for Nick to react to?
It was a day ago. [__]
Ah, I would have liked it if he could have reacted to the Anisa
clip, but >> for literally an hour and a half, and we still
don't
>> I also >> Listen, I'm now obsessed with everybody
else's obsession with Anisa. So, if I see Nicholas reacting to
an Anisa clip, I'm going to watch it, okay? >> Uh then
Anisa said she wanted to bully
>> I also want to say I don't >> Dude, Anisa has
gone Actually,
Anisa is turning into Conquest.
It's like Nicholas, the goat. >> Ah, reference Reference
coming up. One second. I'll be back. >> Thank you for the
$5, my man. >> Dude, Anisa's like The others came here
trying to tell you of a of a different path you could take for
the Viltrumite Empire. I just want you to resist. >> Let's
Dude,
>> honestly, this is kind of base. She's like, "Yeah, dude,
I don't uh You don't understand. The others are going to come
here and tell you a tale of how you need to fight for your people,
and I'm kind of hoping you're
>> I also want to say I don't want AB to leave at this
point. I actually want him to stay and be an eternal L.
>> So, I'm just putting it out there. When I bully him,
it's just because I want to bully him. >> For whatever
reason, with certain discussions, you know what I mean? Like
They didn't >> I can't believe she's just straight up reacting
to the show. We might have to do another segment. >> work
with Hasan. They didn't They weren't here for >> That's
funny. Featuring the cricket. Wait, what? >> I want to
say I don't want AB to leave. >> Oh my god, you Dude, that's
actually
>> At this point, I actually want him to >> There's
a screaming cricket in the back of all of her new clips, isn't
there? I I didn't even hear it. Oh, you just [__]
ruined it.
Three topics tonight be damned. >> What is this? Testicular
sunset. >> What is this? What is this? What is this? Oh,
yeah, I was going to go over her tweets replying to Cheleepy
as well. She's like quoting and retweeting Cheleepy, right? >> Dude,
I guess he didn't like people pointing out that he looks like
a chode with arms. This is the Instagram thing.
Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Anisa snarking Nicholas De Oreo?
I just need I just need Keemstar Casino to get it on board, okay?
I'm still just saying it. I'm thinking it I'm thinking it all
the time. As soon as Keemstar Casino gets on board with the
As soon as she gets on board with the snarking Sorry, as soon
as they get on board with the snarking of Nicholas De Oreo and
the H3 crew uh it's going to be good. It's going to be good.
It looks like he's got Benjamin Button syndrome. There are some
pictures where he just looks like an old lady, yeah. He does
kind of just look like an old lady, yeah. That's true.
Wait, hold on. Should I just Should I just real quick throw the
the lollipop picture in there? Somebody sent me the lollipop
picture. I It's really a waste of the lollipop picture not to
reply with it, right? Hold on, did that not copy? Can I Can you
Can you Can you work? Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. There it goes.
All right. All right, we are continuing.
We're not done with this yet. It's only
No, we're going to do three topics tonight. Featuring the cricket,
all you need to know is this, when the facts don't align with
something that comes out of Anisa's mouth, it's most definitely
projection. Subconsciously, she's truly in hell. The reason she
hates AB is cuz she thought they'd have a mutually assured destruction
pact cuz he vented to her and Ian about Ethan and his boss and
thought that that would he'd be their main man inside or quit
lest they reveal the grievances. Yeah. >> Is Dark Viper
AU a virgin? >> No, I am not. >> Why would so many
people be calling you a virgin? >> it. Oh, wait, this one's
not worth it. This is him saying that they tried to steal the
class bit on the H3 podcast. This one is an intro from the other
day. This is a banger clip. Have you seen this one? >> Elisa
is overriding you. You're fading away. She's siphoning your energy.
She already replied. Hold on. She like instantly replied. What?
Wait, what? Oh, no, she replied to the other thing.
>> I do understand why she'd be upset. I have to block
you. I don't even know you. Why is this on my timeline?
>> I'm sorry, I have to repost it first. I'm sorry, I have
to repost it first. It has to be reposted first. That's just
the way it is. Okay? Now, feel free to block now. I understand.
Trust me, if this was if this was me in that situation, I would
get it. I would get it. Okay? I would get it. I would get
We keep going. We keep going. Wait, I think we're done with Nick,
right? We're done with Nick. We'll go on to Oh, one more one
more reaction?
What is this one? I don't know what this one is. You're winning
my >> that, but we'll watch this real quick and then I
think we got we got the Daniel Biz thing, which could be fun.
I don't know if I'm missing any links in the the Daniel Biz thing.
I've got the woman on Blue Sky who made the allegation and then
I've got another tweet about it. I don't really have anything
else, so we'll we'll take a quick look. You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I've watched Yeah, we watched the sleepy video
earlier. Yep.
Yippee yap. It's the same as Zaugch. I don't care. I don't know.
Zaugch, wait, DID I I SAY I NO, I WOULD NEVER I would never do
anything
>> It's the same as zog chow? >> Why can't you say
zog chow? Say the word with me, Nicholas. Zog chow.
Dog chow, okay? These are the same
Why is he Why is he like this?
>> She's smarter than a box. >> Dude, we got to do
a tier list of what slurs are If they're If it's above a B tier,
we can't say it. >> of the year. The best commentator of
the >> See head is about the Tiananmen Square
>> Guys should be smacking Sleepy for bone smashing. Yeah,
but if I do that, I'm worried he might find me. We both live
in Canada. He might find me one day and hit me with that chin,
and I'll shatter into a thousand pieces, okay? So, you can talk
Sleepy. I'm going to keep safe I'm going to keep safe over here,
okay? I do not want to get hit with that chin. That is a deadly
weapon. >> A sucker. Because they're like zippers from
the tank treads. >> That's [__] up. >> Go
there and hold that that that younger girl, hold her, and >> I
didn't know that was a Tiananmen Square thing, like a Scott Tiananmen
Square thing. I thought I just thought that was like a World
War II thing.
See, I didn't know everything. I knew it was about the tanks,
cuz that's what iDubbbz taught me, but I thought it was the tanks
in World War II, but that doesn't I don't think they had
tanks in Japan, did they? >> You say this word in her ear.
>> She was the I don't know. I Anything I say about World
War II isn't as stupid as Anisa Jomha saying that um
that Japan was completely surrendered prior to the bombs dropping.
>> Yeah, she was the one driving there. She did the whole
thing. >> Yeah, Harley, you did not make money from being
racist.
>> Yeah, I don't think that's true, but
>> Did we have tanks in Japan during World War II? Cuz
my understanding is
>> it was like Dude, HOW DID YOU JUST CALL HER DUMB? HOW
THE did you just call her dumb and follow up with that? This
This guy is serious right now. Dude, that's crazy. That was crazy.
>> It was a lot of like
I don't know. >> I believe he asked if if we had tanks
in Japan as in were there American tanks in Japan in World War
II. Wait, did did America actually invade Okinawa? Wait, Okinawa
Oh, I didn't even know that. Oh, maybe I'm the stupid one then.
If they used tanks. Why would they bring
That's crazy.
>> It was just like the location probably wouldn't have
allowed for it. No tanks. >> Thank you, Daredevil. >> The
Halloween contest >> Apparently they're saying no tanks
too >> You didn't know cuz it was a lot of it was like
dense forest, right? It's not like there was a lot of
>> 15 years before that say they did. >> So, let
me get this >> You did a costume and he influenced >> Starting
the Korean War, okay. >> a generation
to say the end >> Jesus, stop. Is there any like actual
shame in >> Listen, I I don't follow World War No, I'm
sorry, never mind.
I don't follow Japanese World War II history up until 1945, okay?
I like hear about the zeros being on the aircraft carriers and
then like taking over the Pacific and then it gets really sad,
all right? And then it gets really sad after that. >> and
asking the question and not knowing. Again, nobody's coming here
for >> True. I >> I'm an attempted history minor.
I didn't take the last class, so I'm not expected to know this.
>> I do think iDubbbz did have a lot of >> If I came
off and I was trying to >> iDubbbz doing this dragon thing
is so dumb, but it's it like makes me laugh at how it triggers
other people.
Is this like this is like um Nefarian or something, isn't it?
Am I crazy? >> call myself like an expert on World War
>> Oh, no, it wouldn't be Nefarian. It's like not the art
style. It's not the correct art style. It looks kind of like
that, but it can't be. >> But like I learned about World
War II from Call of Duty.
>> fluency, which makes sense why he would apologize in
the way that he did and these two disgusting Zionist losers.
>> The only reason I even played that game was to unlock
Nocturne Totem, dude.
Would uh would support it at the time. Be like, "Oh, this is
good." And now they're like, "I die. He simply
>> But they also made money from it. >> Can I say
something to you, Nick? >> I really like >> think
it's kind of a dagger for Idol.
it's whatever. K, are we
Are we done with this? It feels like we're pretty close to done
with Nick's stream here. I don't think there's anything else
interesting going on. He's got one more reaction to a reaction
of
A Robs Media reaction to something.
He's watching a Robs Media video.
Oh, come on. Come on, YouTube. >> [__] you
up. >> What is this? Anisa Jomha's hour-long meltdown,
she addressed everything.
He's watching his own video. >> full rant from her live
stream. >> Is he watching it? >> Let me set up the
switch. >> Must be. Okay, we're good. We're good on this,
I think. Wait, check the ends. Hold on. People sending me many
things.
Did you notice that
she made her No way.
Wait, hold on.
This is This is the picture. Wait, no way. Dude.
Is she embodying this kind of hater energy? There's no way. Hold
on. There's this picture here.
Wait. Wait, somebody's pointing something out out to me here.
Anisa just tweet Oh, wait, I Hold on. I'm not going to get caught
by that this Wait, wait, here? Perfect. Boom.
Now you click on this. Now
Did she Somebody's suggesting that she may have made this picture
of Nicholas DeOrio her lock screen. Look at the Look at the the
timer here. Did she make this like her wallpaper?
Is this her wallpaper right now? Dude, that's crazy hater energy.
All right. That's wild That's wild hater energy.
>> She's just like this is my enemy. Of course I can't
feel bad about myself. This is my enemy.
>> Oh
my god. Okay. Okay.
Dude, that's wild. That's really wild. This is my enemy would
be good motivation. Not going to lie. I feel like that's what
it is, right? She's like just remember
This is This is the person who tries to tear you down.
This is the person who's trying to tear you down, okay? Just
remember always. Remember always in your heart of hearts this
is the guy.